>> MEIER: Good morning everyone and welcome
to a special tablet week edition of Android
Developers Strike Back.
>> NI-LEWIS: Tablet week is like Shark Week
except not nearly as boring.
>> MEIER: That's true.
That's not only true.
In fact, we're going to have to look at three
tablet apps today.
We've got the developers from Mint, TinyCompany
and the Instapaper developers as well.
>> NI-LEWIS: I think they actually call themselves
TinyCo.
>> MEIER: TinyCo.
>> NI-LEWIS: TinyCo.
>> MEIER: All right.
Okay.
>> NI-LEWIS: TinyCompany kind of sounds like
one of their games actually.
>> MEIER: Actually, that's very true.
All right.
Well, we will--we will ask the TinyCo guys
about their naming choice for their brand
when we speak to them.
So, we got those three apps to go through.
We're going to kind of spend about 10 minutes
on each.
Find out a little bit about their experience
developing for tablets; what successes they've
had; what tips they've got for other developers
looking to develop for tablet as well.
>> NI-LEWIS: Excellent.
So, I think we're going to start with Mint.com.
>> MEIER: We are--we are going to start with
Mint.com.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
Let's see if I got the slides right.
>> MEIER: Oh.
>> TAN: There we go.
>> NI-LEWIS: Hey, check that out.
>> MEIER: Nice, very nice.
So, welcome.
Thank you for joining us.
>> TAN: Hi.
>> MEIER: So you want to introduce yourself.
Tell us a little bit about yourself and Mint.
>> TAN: Sure.
So, my name is Brian Tan and I'm actually
the product owner for the Android side for
Mint.com.
So, I'm just happy to be here.
I'm happy to talk to a little bit about Mint
and kind of our tablet experience.
>> MEIER: Outstanding.
So, I'm going to ask the same few questions
to everyone.
I think we start off; just tell us a little
bit about Mint, about the app which you've
designed for tablet.
You know, a little bit about the experiences
around, you know, what makes this a tablet
specific version of the app?
>> TAN: Sure.
So, you know, Mint.com, first off, is a way
for you to take a look at your finances on
your tablet.
Essentially, we aggregate all of your various
accounts, you know, credit accounts, checking
accounts and things of that sort on the tablet
so that you can have one view of your finances
and basically stay on top of them.
You know, we have a website and then we wanted
to build a tablet app.
And so what we did is we decided to take kind
of the best of what was on the Web and then
bring it to the tablet.
But more specifically, you know, we want to
build this thing from the ground up.
We want to make it native.
And then we said we want to make it cool,
we want to make it interesting.
I mean finances, for the most part, people
don't really think of it as cool and interesting,
right?
>> MEIER: No.
It's not what I do for fun.
>> TAN: Yeah.
So, you know, on the--on the overview screen
here that we've got, you know, basically we
have tried--just tried to make it a very rich
experience.
>> MEIER: Okay.
>> TAN: You know we have a nice little graphic
in the upper left-hand corner.
>> NI-LEWIS: Dan, can you bring that up actually?
>> Yeah.
Just one second.
>> TAN: Sure.
Just so that you could quickly see kind of,
you know where your finances are in terms
of what you're spending.
We've got nice little bar graphs in the right
and then nice little icons that represent
spending there.
>> NI-LEWIS: By the way, I hope you don't
mind that I totally stole this UI for my custom
controls class.
I don't know if you saw that.
>> TAN: No, I didn't actually see that, but
that's cool.
We like--we like to hear that.
I mean...
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, I remember that you guys
came in to show us this...
>> MEIER: So nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...when I--I think it was actually
pre-Honeycomb watch.
>> MEIER: I think it was.
>> TAN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And we were having some problems
because, you know, of course that was a new
GPU for everybody.
>> TAN: Right.
>> NI-LEWIS: And there were some--there were
some issues.
We couldn't get our hardware accelerate at
the normal canvas and it wasn't working quite
fast enough.
And, you know, we looked at it, it wasn't
buttery smooth and you guys really wanted
to be really super smooth.
And so we--I think we ended up recommending
that you draw it on its own hardware layer.
>> TAN: Yeah.
No, definitely.
I mean that was--this screen right here, this
mini by category screen is kind of that one
thing that we want to get right.
We wanted to make sure that interact with
your finances was kind of this very immersive
experience and that buttery smooth, you know,
rotation of the screen just clicking on or
tapping on the slices, even slowing down to
kind of, you know, move between the slices.
We wanted to get that 100% right, and that
was just something that we poured a lot of
effort and a lot of time into.
So...
>> MEIER: It's really nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
Yeah.
>> MEIER: It really gives that feeling that
this is an app that--it feels solid.
>> TAN: Right.
>> MEIER: You know.
>> TAN: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: It's like there's no jankiness,
there's no, "Oh, I can see what they tried
to do there."
It just kind of works exactly as you'd hope
it does.
>> TAN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: You can see--one thing that may
not come out in the video but, something that
really impressed us and really made it run
slower is there's a really light gradient
all the way around here.
And, you know, we talk a lot about gradients.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: In [INDISTINCT] there are some
design guides belonging to our competitors
that emphasize gradients in a way that we
find less Androidy.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: But this is a great use of gradients.
It's a wonderful--it's--you wouldn't even
know it's there if it wasn't pointed out to
you; but it makes the whole thing feel a little
deeper, a little more...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...lifelike.
And of course it slowed down rendering because
the gradients at that time were done in software.
But once you rendered that all out onto one
layer, then you can rotate the layer without
actually having to redraw all the gradients
every time.
>> TAN: Yeah.
I mean, you know, our designers are very thankful
that you noticed the gradient.
I'm thankful of it.
I mean, again, it's just one of those things
that, you know, in addition to the interaction
piece and getting that right.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> TAN: You know the visual aspect, the colors,
the gradients and even kind of the blend of
the colors, you know, we spent a lot of time
on that and we're very, very proud of it.
>> MEIER: Well, it's one of those big challenges.
I mean it seems funny; like, it's such a deceptively
simple screen that we're looking at here.
It's a simple pie.
Well, doing that chart, you know, with a simple
sort of explanation of what each thing represents,
but it's all of those little things.
Like I have--I think anyone who's done any
kind of engineering for any amount of time
has built charting controls from scratch because
it's like databases.
>> TAN: Right.
>> MEIER: It's a requirement of every job
you ever do to start from the beginning.
And even simple things like choosing what
colors you're going to have because you don't
necessarily know how many categories you're
going to have.
So, it's a pseudo-random color generator but
you need to make sure that each one is noticeable
and that they look well together and, you
know, I think that attention to detail really
was worth it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, and even making it a doughnut
instead of a pie.
I think...
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: And I don't know if this is what
you had in mind, but it feels like that gives
me a clue that I'm going to interact with
it instead of just looking at it.
>> TAN: Yeah.
>> MEIER: But it looks like one of those spinning
wheels, you know.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> TAN: Yeah.
You know, like the Wheel of Fortune.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: Like that's the--that's the one
thing that, you know, when I did my version,
I had to add in was the, you know, the ability
to [MAKES NOISE].
So, I just...
>> MEIER: And we're spending money along the...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: Awesome fitness.
>> NI-LEWIS: Make it spin faster and faster.
Yeah.
Great.
>> MEIER: Very cool.
All right.
So, I guess the two questions I had.
So, the first one is, so you already had a
phone app and a website before you had the
tablet app.
What would you say is sort of the biggest
change that you've made in order to make something
which was really a great tablet experience
as opposed to the--to the phone version and
sort of, you know, more than that, what were
the results or, you know, what did you do
and how has that affected your install rate
or your engagement to or any of those sorts
of things?
>> TAN: Right.
So, you know, when we first developed the
tablet app, as you said, we had a phone app
already.
And, you know, we weren't 100% sure kind of
where folks would fall in terms of how they
would use both apps.
So, we said let's release a basic version
of the tablet app and then let's kind of get
some data and let's iterate against that.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> TAN: And so, one of the things that we
started to find with the tablet app is that
people were actually spending more time on
the tablet app.
Basically, they're sitting there they're looking
back at their finances and they're also looking
forward into their finances.
>> MEIER: So as you said, the analysis and
plan?
>> TAN: Exactly.
Whereas on the phone, it's kind of like this
decision maker.
You know like, you might be at the store and
you might decide should I really buy this
TV?
And you pop open this thing and figure out
yes, I can, right?
>> MEIER: How much is in my consumer electronics
budget for this?
>> TAN: Right.
Exactly.
And then so, we started to move down that
route of empowering the user on the tablet
to do things like, you know, editing budgets
and doing split transactions and just being
able to do more in terms of really kind of
setting their financial foundation and, you
know, looking back at their data and making
sure it's kind of jiving with what they think.
>> MEIER: Yes.
>> TAN: So, you know, our analogy is our phone
app is basically a snacking app; like, throughout
the day you're popping peanuts or you're,
you know, eating, you know, candy bars and
whatnot.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> TAN: And then with the tablet app, it's
basically like a full meal.
You sit down and you'll kind of digest the
overview and then you'll, you know, go deeper
into budgets and you start editing your budgets
and things of that sort.
>> MEIER: I like that.
That's a--that's a nice analogy.
So, if I understand that correctly, so you're
actually--are you actually putting your spending
into the app as you're spending it?
And so if you're out at the shops, you're
actually putting that budgetary information
in via the phone app?
>> TAN: Yeah.
So, basically on your tablet app, you can
go and set your budgets, you can edit your
budgets and then when you have your phone
app, you know, that very same budget that
you've set, you can clearly see how much money
you've got left...
>> MEIER: Yes.
>> TAN: ...for this particular month and then
you can dive deeper into the various, you
know, subcategories and whatnot.
And then, you know, conversely when you're
on your phone, you can enter transactions
on the go and on the fly.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> TAN: And then when you get home, you know,
you can see them showing up on your table.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
Yeah.
>> TAN: And then you can go in and do a little
bit more if you wanted to.
>> MEIER: Nice.
You can find out what punishment you've done
to your budgets...
>> TAN: Yeah.
>> MEIER: ...on your phone when you get back
home.
>> TAN: Yeah.
>> MEIER: That's nice.
So, does that mean that the tablet app; is
that something that's sort of a feature for
feature equivalent of what you can do on the
website?
Do you just sort of see that in the future
as sort of becoming more and more the way
that maybe people are going to be using the
app?
[INDISTINCT]
>> TAN: Definitely.
>> MEIER: ...of problem with it.
>> TAN: I mean, you know, you kind of hit
the nail on the head in terms of, you know,
we've got a website; we've got a tablet and
we've got a phone.
You know, where the tablet sit in between
and it's looking more and more like, you know,
it may kind of replace the Web.
I mean, it kind of, you know, what--so we're
bringing some of those more Web-like features
to the tablet and then we'll keep the phone
to be very simple, very decision-oriented
or kind of enter information-oriented and
then on the tablet, you can do your analysis.
>> MEIER: Nice.
I mean that's, I think, something which we
go on about quite a bit, which is the idea
that on a--on a phone, you really want to
have almost a single action.
>> TAN: Yup.
>> MEIER: Sort of you open it up and there's
sort one or two steps to do whatever it is
you want to do.
Check to see whether I can but this thing
or, you know, basically enter the information
that I have for this thing.
>> TAN: Right.
>> MEIER: Whereas on the tablet, you are expecting
people to sit down and spend a bit more time,
so you can have a little bit more of a complex
work for them...
>> TAN: Yeah.
>> MEIER: ...or have more complex actions
to take.
>> TAN: Yeah.
And our data tells us exactly that.
I mean, you know to the point about snacking
and dining.
I mean, on the tablet app, you know, we see
most people hopping into the app at about
8:00, you know, after 8:00 PM.
>> MEIER: You're right.
>> TAN: And that's when our usage spikes,
between 8:00 and 10:00.
So, you know...
>> MEIER: Nice.
>> TAN: ...maybe folks put the kids down to
bed and then they pick up Mint for, you know,
or maybe they're in bed talking with their
wife or husband or whatnot about their finances.
>> MEIER: We really need this TV and look
we can make it work.
>> TAN: Exactly.
>> MEIER: I can see that.
>> NI-LEWIS: Nice.
>> MEIER: That's cool.
And so, did you see then--obviously you've
got a lot of analytics which is, again, something
which we tell people that they need to do.
You know, you need to understand what impact
the decisions you're making about your app
has on its usage.
So, did you see as you were sort of adding
more of that dining experience to tablet that
you're usage was increasing?
>> TAN: Yeah, definitely.
I mean we've seen, you know, a fair amount
of usage in terms of just, you know, installs
with the app.
And then just in terms of, you know overall
time spent in the app.
>> MEIER: Oh, great.
>> Tan: You know I believe the number was
in the magnitude of 25% more time on the app...
>> NI-LEWIS: Wow.
>> TAN: ...you know, versus on the phone.
So, you know, again big thing for us, you
know, to know that and to kind of make that
decision and go down that path.
>> MEIER: Very cool.
That sounds like a--that sounds like a lot
of thought and effort has gone into every
aspect of this, which is really great to see
and you can see that from polished effect.
>> NI-LEWIS: Definitely.
>> MEIER: It--the other thing I want to point
out as well because we had Mint, I think was
one of the nominees for one of our app clinics
a while back but we didn't spend much time
on it because A, it was already great and
B, we didn't have a demo account to log into.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: But, you know, one thing I want
to highlight for people watching is that this
is an app that looks very much like Mint.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: It doesn't--it doesn't look a lot
like hollow.
It's got more gradients than we would usually
expect to see.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: Things like these reflections.
But it really works.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, yeah.
>> MEIER: You know, I think that's something
which we spend a lot of time telling people
like sometimes you can watch our show and
think we're basically saying make every app
look like it should be a native app like,
you know, that is shipped with the fun.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
Make everything flat.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: Flat.
>> MEIER: Flat, nothing.
>> NI-LEWIS: And to be fair, Roman Newark
does say that.
>> MEIER: But this is a really good example
of going the whole way.
So it's like...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...it doesn't have to be that.
This still looks consistent with Android;
it looks like it belongs on this device.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: But it does look different to some
of the native apps which shipped with it.
And I think...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: ...it really just comes down to
having this holistic design that fits everything
in.
You know, you've got this action bar which
looks like legitimate action bar; I mean it
is.
You've got...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
It works right.
Everything, everything is in the right place.
>> MEIER: That's right.
If I want to...
>> NI-LEWIS: It's where you expect it to be.
>> MEIER: ...do something, I can refresh;
I know here I've I got, you know, the compose
icon meaning, you know, to add something in.
It's all intuitive.
It all works...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...the way I would expect.
>> NI-LEWIS: And nothing--now, I have--I don't
think I've seen every nook and cranny of this
app.
But just as I--as I played with it, this is
probably the fourth or fifth time I've had
a chance to sit down and play with it.
What's really impressive is that nothing feels
stitched on.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: There's never that point that
we get to with a lot of other apps where we
say, "Oh, this is where they ran out of time
and stopped."
>> MEIER: And this is where the designers
also run out in the develop point, "Oh, you
know, what I could do?"
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
And you can see that they've solved a lot
of difficult technical problems.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Look.
This is a--this is a buttery smooth thing,
I don't know if you noticed but there's a
little fade out gradient...
>> MEIER: I did notice that, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...at the top there which--actually,
you know, isn't--in fact, I will say that
a couple of versions ago, there were some
devices where we had to take that gradient
out because we couldn't make our GPU code
run fast enough.
>> MEIER: It's--this is really a good example
actually of using the inspiration of hollow
and of the Android theming and applying it
within your own app.
Because we, you know, we have something similar
with this when you get to the top and bottom
of a ListView.
And this clearly isn't a ListView, but it
still has that same hinting as to there's
more up, you know.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yup.
Exactly.
>> MEIER: So it's really nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yup.
All right.
>> MEIER: Very cool.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: So I think we've probably spend
enough time on Mint.
So thank you very for coming in...
>> TAN: Sure.
>> MEIER: ...and joining us and talk a little
bit about the product.
We should get some other guys a chance.
So...
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
>> MEIER: ...let's move on to TinyCo.
>> NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
One of my--one of my...
>> MEIER: Can you guys hear us and see us
all right?
>> NI-LEWIS:...favorites.
And there's a chair for you right on there.
>> TAN: Oh, cool.
Oh.
>> MEIER: Hey guys.
>> MAHER: Hi.
How are you?
>> NI-LEWIS: Hey, hey.
>> MEIER: I'm very well.
>> NI-LEWIS: Good to see you.
We're going to shift over around here because...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...we don't have any high tech
where--we need like a little chair carousel.
That would be awesome.
>> MEIER: Oh, no.
We need like a trapdoor because we're on--we're
on the second floor.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's true.
>> MEIER: I guess because we're in the US.
I suggest lower people out and lower them
back in.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
As long...
>> MEIER: And then we'll just [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: ...as we're making an 80k project,
we can expense it.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
So first question.
TinyCo, yes?
Not Tiny Company?
>> MAHER: Yes, TinyCo.
>> MEIER: Excellent.
That's probably a good choice.
So apologies for mangling your company name.
>> MAHER: That's all right.
>> MEIER: Do you want to introduce yourself?
And tell us a little bit about TinyCo.
>> MAHER: Sure.
I'm Sean Maher.
I'm one of the mobile developers here.
We make mobile games.
Most of them are premium games with in app
purchase and yeah, we've been moving everything
that we can onto the Android store and trying
to support as many devices as possible including
the tablets.
>> MEIER: Outstanding.
So let's say, so we've installed Tiny Monsters,
I think...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: ...you know, on the device.
Do you--we've got it up on screen.
Do you want to tell us a little a bit about
the game?
Perhaps, you know--it looks great on tablets
and maybe talk a little bit about the tablet
aspects and any differences that this may
have with the phone version.
>> MAHER: Sure.
Yeah.
I mean we pictured that people would be using
the tablet version, you know, maybe at their
desks; but probably on their couch or in bed
or something like that.
We definitely knew that people wanted to get
a bigger and better view of their island.
For anyone who hasn't played the game, you
have your own island that you decorate and
buy habitats in and then you hatch and raise
different monsters and then crossbreed them.
>> MEIER: Nice.
>> MAHER: But we wanted to make sure that
people got as big and as clear a view of the
island as possible.
So we took advantage of the full side of the--size
of the screen and we made sure that we had
high resolution assets for all of the buildings,
all of the monsters...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> MAHER: ...everything that people would
be seeing.
>> MEIER: The assets look fantastic, I think.
It's only...
>> MAHER: Yeah.
>> MEIER: ...the first thing that I noticed
like you got the full screen experience with
the--sort of the chrome, the game chrome is
big enough without being too big.
So it doesn't look like it's being stretched
but it's all big enough to touch and the assets
just look gorgeous, really crisp.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
You guys have come such a long way since.
I remember when we first got in touch, you
guys were working on--was it Tap Resort or
the--this little island game?
>> MAHER: Yes.
Yeah.
That would have been Tap Resort.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
And that was--the first thing that we noticed
was, you know, the assets didn't' scale very
well and there were just, you know, lot of
things would come over from phone.
And I remember we sat down and talked to you
about, you know, the different, you know,
form factors in Android and it took a while.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: But it seems like you guys really
took that to heart.
I mean didn't you go back and basically you
wrote a cross platform engine which works
really well.
You were able to get great performance out
of it.
But most importantly you've got this images
that look...
>> MEIER: Wow.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...just fantastic even with this
really high zoom places.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
It's zoomed...
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm very, very impressed with
that.
>> MEIER: ...in here.
This looks fantastic.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MAHER: Yeah.
We did--we were originally with the older
game that you were talking about.
We were porting our apps and essentially had
two different code bases running but...
>> MEIER: Always fun.
>> MAHER: ...when we started to take this
very seriously, we knew that we needed a cross
platform engine which we wrote and probably
one of the biggest challenges was how were
we going to deal with all these different
aspect to ratios and--because we knew that
we were--we were now dealing with more than
one screen size and just stretching everything
wasn't going to cut it.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know, one thing I do remember
too is that, you know, that we had a talk
and I think you actually, if I remember right,
had an excellent blog post about just how
you were able to grow your revenue by concentrating
on treating andler--Android like Android instead
of porting from some other platform that didn't
have the same benefits and challenges.
>> MAHER: Right, yeah.
It has been a whole different--it's a whole
different ecosystem and different strategies
have worked well for us.
I'm a coder, so I'm not--I probably can't
speak too much to the--to the financial side
of things.
But we have treated each platform--on the
engineering side, it's all fairly unified.
But the monetization strategies are very different
on each ecosystem.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: That's interesting.
You know, given that you are on the engineering
side, I'd like to dig a little bit deeper
if possible to find out, you know, what was
some of the techniques that you used to get
past the--that challenge that you said of
all the different aspect ratios and screen
sizes, so is that something that you can share
with some of the developers watching to--and
probably facing a lot those same issues.
>> MAHER: Sure.
Sure.
Absolutely.
Like a lot of games, we are using the Endeca.
We're writing the bulk of our game code in
C++.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> MAHER: And the--look, like I said, right
out of the game, we knew we needed to deal
with this--not so much the screen size issue,
but the aspect ratio issue.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yes.
>> MAHER: Some devices are extremely wide-screened.
Others are taller, you know, than the standard,
you know, the four by three phone aspect ratio.
>> MEIER: I've seen a lot of games which have
sort of the black bars along the side to say
it...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...really is four three, trust me.
>> MAHER: Right.
Yeah.
We don't--we don't pretend that it's four
three.
We actually--so since we're using the native
development kit, we're not using a lot of
the built-in Android features for scaling
and whatnot.
We look at the raw number of pixels on the
screen...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> MAHER: ...and based on that decide how
much we're going to have to scale the UI elements
and the game elements.
Beyond that, we do have high-resolution assets
that we use.
If we do decide we need to scale a button
to twice its original size, we used a double
size art asset for that.
So it doesn't look blurry like it...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> MAHER: ...would be if you just--if you
just scaled it up without using a larger asset.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's a really interesting point.
Do you make that decision initially based
on the screen size which assets you'll load
or do you actually make it on an asset by
asset basis trying to determine how much it's
going to scale?
>> MAHER: We don't do the--second technique
you're talking about would be like level of
detail based on...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> MAHER: ...how big it is, decide which asset
to use.
We don't do that.
We decide based on the raw number of pixels
in the display.
We think we're going to need, you know, single
size assets or double size assets.
>> NI-LEWIS: So do you bucket them--I'm really
curious.
Do you bucket them the same way we do or do
you have a different scheme?
>> MAHER: I'm not sure if you--I know in the
standard Android STK there's a number of folders
for medium resolution and high resolution
and things like that.
We have what we call just the single resolution,
the one X and the double resolution, the two
X.
We're not using other...
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
>> MAHER: ...intermediate sizes.
>> NI-LEWIS: Got you.
>> MEIER: That probably makes sense; and in
fact we've...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...we've actually found that for
most cases, that actually works pretty well.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: Like it's not always necessary even
when you're using the STK, to use each of
those buckets.
And in fact when you have, you know, just
providing something very high res which can
then scale back works pretty well until we
get to the point where you almost needed a
different style asset to work at the reduced
resolution.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Of course you're also doing some quite fancy
scaling work here.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
It has some sort of zooming in...
>> NI-LEWIS: Or actually...
>> MEIER: ...on the--on the world.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
We're zooming in and out; and is that just
a set of mipmap textures or do you--do you...
>> MAHER: We're actually--we're not using
mipmaps, we're just...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-huh.
>> MAHER: ...using the single--the single
high resolution texture.
That's why you can zoom in as far as you are
so that a single building feels like the entire
screen.
>> MEIER: Wow.
>> MAHER: Because we are using those high
resolution textures.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, absolutely.
>> MAHER: Yeah.
Mipmaps are really nice for scaling but of
course they use a lot more memory.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MAHER: And we are still somewhat memory
constrained.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's really interesting.
>> MEIER: Politically correct.
>> NI-LEWIS: I would--well, I would actually
be very interested to know how that affects
your performance because typically, you know,
what we'll see is, Mint maps will take up
more room and memory obviously.
But they'll also...
>> MAHER: Render faster.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly because they're--they
eat less GPU bandwidth on the way in, right?
So...
>> MAHER: Sure.
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm actually really surprised
that you're able to get this frame rate with
nothing but full resolution samples.
>> MAHER: Right.
Well, we were--we just--we've always been
more constrained by memory than we were by
CPU and draw speed.
That may be because we don't have millions
of triangles on the--on the screen.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's a good point.
>> MAHER: But for us, for the kind of games
that we're making right now.
It made more sense to use less memory and
take the hit to the draw speed.
>> NI-LEWIS: Got you.
>> MEIER: Yeah, totally.
It just looks really smooth, so I think that's
really a good choice.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: And I love the graphics, like all
of the graphics look fantastic.
And if we're all of the--even just the style
itself and sort of the faces from the people
who pop up and congratulate you and stuff,
it's just...
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh yeah, absolutely,
>> MEIER: It looks like a lot of fun.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, I remember, I was actually
in the pitch meeting when you guys came and
showed this to us the first time.
And we'd actually just reviewed a whole set
of very, very similar games but this still
really blew us away.
That, you know kudos to your artist.
>> MAHER: Well, thank you.
Yeah, I can't take credit for that.
We have some amazing artists and some amazing
UI people.
>> MEIER: Very cool.
So I was going to ask him.
And you may not be--you may not be the right
person on the team to speak to this but I'll
ask anyway just in case.
Having, you know, really build this excellent
experience on tablet, do you--have you found
any significant difference in terms of user
engagement?
And I mean, frankly you guys have an app which,
you know, is paid.
So if you found that you're making comparatively
more money on users who are using it on tablet
devices?
>> MAHER: Yeah, I don't.
I don't have access to the monetization numbers.
But I do know that the percentage of our users
who are playing on a tablet has been definitely
been going up...
>> MEIER: Good.
>> MAHER: ...over time.
And it's--we definitely take that into consideration
when planning new features, because we know
that that's where a lot of our users want
to play, on a tablet.
>> MEIER: Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
You know if you click the games like this
which sort of more than to just I've got five
minutes while I'm waiting for my bus.
It's more like, okay; I've got an hour or
two to spend gaming now, whether that's on
a train or at home or wherever else.
So, you know, for that experience, I think
tablets are just fantastic.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, and especially when you
want that really beautiful immersive graphical
experience.
>> MEIER: Oh, absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: And this, you know, you can see
very similar graphics on a phone but they
just won't blow you away like they do here.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: I know that I--publicly you guys
have said a few things about how Android was
very disappointing at first for TinyCo but
as we--as we worked with you and as you started
to see the Android ecosystem as a separate
thing.
Especially, you know, being able to take advantage
of things like different aspect ratios, different
sized devices, in a way that made the users
of each device happy.
Then, you know, apparently and this is--again
what you guys said in your blog post, the
monetization just steadily climbed...
>> MEIER: That's right.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...and got much, much better.
And I don't know where it's at now.
That was--I think the last year is when you
guys were saying that.
Actually before this game even came out but...
>> MEIER: But it's great to see that it's...
>> NI-LEWIS: Hopefully it's convenient.
>> MEIER: Oh, you'd like to think so.
The very least I think if we're seeing, you
know, apps or games of this sort of quality
and you guys are still investing your resources
to create them for tablets, that's probably
a good sign.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know, holy crap, they got
clouds and everything.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's awesome.
>> MEIER: I was wondering what those things
were, it's clouds.
>> MAHER: Yeah, right.
>> MEIER: It's just cool.
All right.
Well, we've--we spent a bunch of time on this.
We should give a little bit of a chance to
Instapaper to speak as well.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, absolutely.
>> MEIER: Thank you very much for joining
us and thank you...
>> MAHER: Thank you.
>> MEIER: ...for creating an awesome looking
game.
>> MAHER: Thank you guys.
>> MEIER: All right.
Let's move on.
Such a nice little animation you got going
there, Ian, very impressed.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's almost like magic...
>> MEIER: It...
>>>NI-LEWIS: The way it moves.
>> MEIER: It is almost like...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: ...it's moving magically.
So, the last app that we wanted to talk about
today was Instapaper.
So hopefully we've got the Instapaper guys
on the line, hi guys.
>> ROCK: Hey, how you doing?
>> EMERICK: Hey.
>> MEIER: Pretty good.
Thank you for bearing with us and hanging
around.
We're hopefully saving the best to the last.
No offense to our friend who's just gone before.
It's best to get them out of the room.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: Awkward.
So please introduce yourselves, tell us a
little bit about the company, the app.
>> ROCK: Sure.
So, our company is called Mobelux.
My name is Jeff Rock, I'm co-founder.
I'm here with Jason Emerick who's our lead
Android developer.
So Mobelux, we make apps for IOS, the Mac,
Android, pretty much anywhere there's a screen.
>> MEIER: Nice.
>> ROCK: A lot of our business is building
white label apps for other companies and startups.
So Tumblr, we built their 1st and 2nd generation
Android client.
>> MEIER: Nice.
>> ROCK: We built iHomes, Android client for
their alarm clock.
We built other apps for Random House and some
other guys out there on the store.
You just--you may not see our name but we
have a lot of people using our apps everyday.
>> MEIER: Very cool.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's in business.
>> MEIER: And they've never seen the--they've
never seen 90, probably used one of your apps.
>> ROCK: Yup.
We--this arrangement was a little different.
We're real good friends with Marco Arment
and he came to us and said, "Look, I just
simply don't have the resources to devote
to Android development.
And I know you guys do this stuff."
And he was interested in seeing if we would
build it under our name because he felt like
Instapaper would really shine on Android tablets.
So, we took it over and we developed the Android
code base from scratch.
We maintained it.
We worked closely with Marco on the features
we're going to implement time on.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> ROCK: But it is very much a Mobelux/Instapaper
production.
>> MEIER: Very cool, very cool.
So he came to you guys specifically because
you've got that experience with Android and
sort of understand how to build an app which
is sort of a pure Android experience, is that
right?
>> ROCK: Yeah, I think we're all--especially--Mobelux
in particular and Marco and he feels this
way too.
We really--we loathe that the kind of write
once, run anywhere frameworks.
We don't--in our experience, we've never seen
any of those do it particularly really well.
And I've never heard of anyone that loved
them once they used them, so.
>> MEIER: Yeah, and that's what we've [INDISTINCT]
>> ROCK: We're pretty finicky about being
native for the platform, done the way it's
supposed to be done.
>> MEIER: Yeah, I think that's when it comes
down to me and those write once, run anywhere
type platforms are a great idea?
And I'd be hugely supportive of them if they
produced awesome apps, which I couldn't tell
were built on the write once, you know, run
anywhere type platform.
>> ROCK: Yeah.
>> MEIER: Sadly, that doesn't seem to be the
case.
>> NI-LEWIS: And every time I've ever, you
know, encountered any sort of automatically
generated UIs, it's never good.
>> MEIER: Yeah, exactly.
So, you know, I think at the moment, it's
definitely the way to go is to really try
and build something that is, you know, native
for each one.
And that's the thing as well.
People act as though it's a huge amount of
extra work.
>> ROCK: Sorry, we're losing you just a little
bit, can you say...
>> MEIER: That's all right.
We're just basically talking amongst ourselves
but I see you guys are frozen on our screen
as well.
So we'll continue to talk amongst ourselves
until you unfreeze.
Oh, looks like they're back.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, good.
>> MEIER: I can see some of it right now.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> ROCK: It's okay.
>> MEIER: I can see on that corner.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, great, great.
Yeah, So I think people forget actually the
lessons of history.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because if you can think about
even, you know, the first version of Microsoft
Office for Mac, for instance, and Office for
Mac, a lot of people don't realize is actually
very profitable and...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...well-respected product.
But the first version was universally reviled
and it was mostly because they took their
Windows product and plugged it...
>> MEIER: To the Mac.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...directly on the Mac.
You know, that's never going to fly...
>> MEIER: Yeah, that's right.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...right?
And it doesn't fly to go back the other way
either.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: I've had some, some things that
were obviously written for Mac on my Windows
machine and they just don't jive right.
>> MEIER: So it's one of the little things,
it's like you hit a dropdown and the dropdown
in Mac and Windows is different.
It's exactly the same functionality but it
looks different and it's that cognitive dissonance
where you're like, wait, how do I select this?
Oh, okay.
That slight little pause breaks you out of
that mindset of whatever it is that you were
doing.
So you don't want to have to think about the
app.
You just want to able to do whatever the app
lets you do.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
So respecting the platform and respecting
the user who chose...
>> MEIER: It's really about the user.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...to buy that platform.
>> MEIER: It's like you don't have to worry
about us, you know, we can take it but it's
about the users which you're trying to, you
know, leverage your app.
So we've got--we've got Instapaper up on the
screen.
Can you tell us a little bit about the--the
way that you went about designing a tablet
specific version of the app?
And sort of what are the have the key decisions
that you made and how that has affected usage
of the app.
>> ROCK: Yeah, absolutely.
So I think unlike a lot of Android development,
we started with tablet primarily.
We actually designed out the seven inch and
ten inch layouts for tablets before we even
looked at the thumb-based layouts.
>> MEIER: Yeah, that's interesting.
>> ROCK: We really felt like this was for
the people that read, you know, there's a
lot of competition in the space now.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> ROCK: For read it later style, you know,
consumption.
But Instapaper's really for reading and as
soon as we picked up a seven inch tablet we
really knew that was--that was a great place
to be.
We deploy on to Kindle as well with the same
layouts and Nook.
That was very important because we wanted
to get people that were buying primarily reading
devices as well as certain people in the--in
the Google Play Store that have these tablets.
So, it was a pretty easy decision to make
once we held those tablets.
That the phone would be a secondary place
to run Instapaper and most likely you're going
to want to sit down on your couch or lay in
bed and read on a nice, you know, tablet.
>> MEIER: Just looking at it here, I can see
straight away what it reminds me of is my
Kindle.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: You know, just a great experience
to being optimized for being able to read
contents.
So it's a very simple display, very sparse.
>> ROCK: Yes.
>> MEIER: Without being too small which I
think is important.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> ROCK: Yeah, we really were focused on simplicity.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> ROCK: Instapaper is not a complex interface.
We have a lot of opportunities to create little
UI mechanisms that are fine or maybe a little
overly complex.
And we use this, you know, when we--for Instapaper
this--it really--the simplicity of the experience
is core, I think to that whole product.
>> MEIER: Oh, I totally agree.
I think, you know, it's like you start up
the app and it almost looks and I say this
with respect, it almost looks a little boring.
You know, you open it up and it's like, oh,
it's just bunch of things to read and then
you click them and there's articles to read.
But that...
>> ROCK: Uh-hmm, yeah.
>> MEIER: I think it's kind of a point, right?
There's no distraction, there's no oh, what
does this app do, how I do I use this?
>> IN-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: What features are available?
And it's like...
>> IN-LEWIS: Yeah, they do--yeah, there aren't
any crazy pop-ups or gigantic menus...
>> MEIER: None.
It's just a bunch of stuff...
>> IN-LEWIS: ...which is really...
>> MEIER: ...that you've chosen to read and
provide it in a way for you--optimize for
you to be able to read it, you know...
>> IN-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER:...I love the fact that you can change
the fonts and the profile and everything else.
>> IN-LEWIS: You know, the other thing that
I noticed about this design that I think is
really interesting is a lot of people--well,
almost everyone, I think that writes a tablet
app will start with a two column layout that's
a, you know, a master detail type of thing.
>> MEIER: Yeah, so the navigation on your
left with, you know, detail on the right side
scenario.
>> IN-LEWIS: Right.
And you guys did not do that you go with the
two columns if you--that's--it makes me think
of a newspaper...
>> MEIER: Yeah, very much.
>> IN-LEWIS: ...and I think that's very effective...
>> ROCK: Yup.
>> IN-LEWIS: ...it's a really interesting
layout.
>> ROCK: And so that's just goes to that same
tenet and we believe that the content is king
in Instapaper...
>> IN-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> ROCK: ...and we want to give you as much
content without, you know, we're not just
space filling here, we put two columns up
so that you could see the--the most recent
articles that you save or get a little bit
more content on the screen so you can quickly
and get into that reading experience.
>> MEIER: Yeah, I think that's a really good
point.
The--a lot of the way that this is presented
is like you say it sort of inspired by newspapers,
I would say.
>> IN-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: You know, in that--you can fit probably
as many articles probably not quite as many
if you had just this listed vertically with
the same amount of text but it would look
kind of weird because you'd have these really
long lines of text.
>> IN-LEWIS: No, it wouldn't be nearly as
readable either.
>> MEIER: No, absolutely not.
And so here, you've kind of taken that approach
which we've learned from over many decades
of printing newspapers that people can read
columns much more easily than lots of long
flat strings.
And so, you know, I love to see apps which
take things which we've learned from other
industries and saying well, you know what,
it's actually not that different what you're
creating here is an Instapaper, a way for
people to be able to quickly scan, browse
and read content.
>> IN-LEWIS: Yeah, in fact, I have to say
now when I click through to one of the stories
and it takes up the entire width of the screen
I'm actually kind of disappointed.
>> MEIER: It's interesting--I mean I think
it's one of the bigger challenges.
So I'd been interested to know when you sort
of looking at the detail view for any of the
articles, you know, how much of this is reformatted,
how much of it--are you displaying this just--did
I say just?
So you're displaying this in a web view and
just pulling the raw content out, are you
doing any kind of reformatting to it?
>> EMERICK: Yes, so, the Instapaper app provides
the--just a--basically a raw HTML content...
>> MEIER: Uh-huh.
>> EMERICK: ...we pull that down and catch
it locally on your SD card or your local storage
and then we have a web view that just opens
up that content and we apply a--like a cascading
cell sheet to that and some java script as
well...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> EMERICK: ...and that allows you to--you
have things like change the font size, change
the font, change the line spacing, line height...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> EMERICK: ...the margins that kind of stuff.
>> MEIER: Very cool.
It will be...
>> IN-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> IN-LEWIS: Yeah, they kept this whole...
>> MEIER: Exactly.
And this--we just sort of clicking on the--on
the font control dialogue here and one of
the things that I guess I want to point out
is again, this is another example of an app
which doesn't strictly conform to, like, standard
expectations of how an app should look.
>> IN-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: But it does do some of the--like
wherever it is close it's pretty much the
same...
>> IN-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...so you've got the standard share
icon on what looks like an action bar which
has actions...
>> IN-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...it's obvious the way that it's
working.
I kind of like to see an app affordance here
but that's kind of getting a little bit nitpicky.
>> IN-LEWIS: I think that as--as the app affordance
becomes more and more common people are going
to start really missing it.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
So, that's yeah...
>> ROCK: Yeah, in some of those work you got
to remember that to target things like the
Nook, they'll ask how you did it--Kindle...
>> IN-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: That's a good point.
>> ROCK: ...we have to go back to two, one
and that...
>> IN-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> ROCK: ...and that presented some interesting
problems.
That action bar is not actually, you know,
the ice cream sandwich action bar...
>> MEIER: Yeah, right.
>> ROCK: ... that was built so as the code
base kind of modernizes and we can, you know,
the new Kindles and the new Nooks that--they've
moved off the older code base they're up the
ice cream sandwich now so...
>> MEIER: Nice.
>> ROCK: ...we're going to be able to kind
of move up to using more system frameworks
which we'd rather be using anyway quite honestly.
>> MEIER: That's cool.
>> ROCK: One of those things were I don't
want to say they're hatched, they're not...
>> MEIER: Creative backgrounds.
>> ROCK: ...what probably you guys would like
to see.
>> IN-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: Yeah, and that's fair enough.
So I mean--I guess once you guys are saying
is if we had given you a backwards compatible
action bar you would have used it but we didn't
see you had to do what you could.
>> IN-LEWIS: That's a--that's a familiar story.
Yeah, honestly, there's really only one thing
after playing the app for a while that bothered
me and that's the switch...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> IN-LEWIS:...for dark mode...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> IN-LEWIS: ...that looks like...
>> MEIER: It got me too.
>> IN-LEWIS: ...it may have been lifted from
somewhere else.
>> MEIER: Yeah, the dark mode switch, the
thing which bothers me most in the look is
that it's--it's not hugely responsive...
>> IN-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: ...so I find myself wanting to swipe
it...
>> IN-LEWIS: Right but you have to tap it.
>> MEIER: ...but it doesn't work when you
swipe it, it's a tap.
>> IN-LEWIS: Yeah, and having yeah, something
that looks swipeable, that's only tappable
is actually really frustrating.
>> ROCK: Well, I'm sorry.
We lost you for a minute there, what element
are you talking about?
>> MEIER: Did you...
>> IN-LEWIS: [MAKES NOISE] can't hear you
button.
>> ROCK: Yeah.
>> MEIER: Slick, see what you did there.
The dark mode toggle.
>> ROCK: Uh-hmm.
Yeah.
>> MEIER: It looks like it's swipeable.
>> ROCK: That should be changed, don't worry.
>> IN-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> ROCK: Yeah, it's going to change we know.
And again, some of those were...
>> MEIER: Just a quick thing.
>> ROCK: Yeah, time limitations and we really
wanted to get something out the market but
we're definitely constantly looking at this
interface we're going to be adapting it at
the very near future.
>> MEIER: Very cool.
I mean I think that's--the K to this is it's
simplicity so if were any of the nitpicks
that we have around navigation it's actually
not too big a deal because it's really straightforward
you've only got two levels of nav, you can
never really get lost because there's only
so far you can go.
And you never sort of trying to figure out
where you're at, how does this all work, it
really use that epitome of something which
is easy to use and again one of the things
that we talk about a lot when we talk about
designing for tablet is to make sure that
you don't have excessive white space and I
think one of the tricks that a lot of people
do is they just fill it up with fragments
or whatever to just...
>> IN-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER:...have not those long lines and
so I think that's, you know, I know we've
talked about this a lot but I think that's
what you've done really well here is thought
beyond that as to well, how can we fill this
in a way that makes it a better experience
rather than just less sucky experience.
>> IN-LEWIS: And not just better but more
appropriate to the activity...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> IN-LEWIS: ...at hand.
>> MEIER: Yeah, exactly.
>> IN-LEWIS: You know, with--at the very beginning
of the show we looked at Mint.com which also
filled space really, really well and they
did it by having sort of a multi-pane view
that felt like a, you know, a little bit like
a spaceship control center which I think was
really appropriate to this idea of controlling
your money whereas...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> IN-LEWIS: ...this feels a lot more like
it just opened up the afternoon paper and
I'm going to take a read.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
I think that's really good observation is
sort of that difference where Mint did have
sort of the gradients and the rounding to
make it sort of a more rich, sort of 3D, sort
of experience and this is exactly the opposite,
this is about as flat as an app can be without
disappearing into the background entirely
it's quite monochromatic.
It doesn't have blends or gradients or anything
like that because well books and newspapers
don't, right?
It's just black and white text optimized for
you to be able to read.
>> IN-LEWIS: But of course, you know, you
can see where they wanted to have, you know,
put in some nice design touches...
>> MEIER: Exactly.
>> IN-LEWIS: ...it's not that's it's not designed
it's just...
>> MEIER: No, no.
>> IN-LEWIS: ...it's designed this way.
>> MEIER: It's designed the minimalistic way.
>> IN-LEWIS: Yeah, exactly.
>> MEIER: I think that's the really important
thing, you know, it's tempting for us as engineers
I think sometimes to go oh, look at the things
I can do...
>> IN-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: ...and then to do them but that
can sometimes detract from a much more simple
experience which can be easy for people to
use.
>> IN-LEWIS: Well, we'll be really looking
forward to your next release.
I know there's a bunch of little things I
think we've given some feedback already, you
know, there was that [INDISTINCT] the way
icons are laid out on the action bar didn't
quite fit the brand new guidelines that just
came out a few months ago but I think you
guys are aware of all that and can't wait
to see what you guys come up with in your
next version.
>> MEIER: Definitely.
The last thing...
>> ROCK: Yup.
>> MEIER: ...I did want to ask you guys I
think we're well over the time we had initially
planned.
>> IN-LEWIS: Yeah, because we've optimistically
budgeted half an hour for talking to three
different developers that we're very interested
in talking to.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
>> IN-LEWIS: It's...
>> MEIER: We don't care if anyone else is
watching we've had a really good time.
>> IN-LEWIS: That's quite true.
>> MEIER: So the one thing I did want to ask
so you started with tablet, have you built
a phone version as well now?
>> ROCK: No, absolutely.
Yeah, and I think it more falls in your guidelines
than the newer guidelines actually.
>> MEIER: That's kind of cool.
>> ROCK: And then the tablet interface does
but yeah, we absolutely run on phones at every
density and extremely outsize including the
newer--with the Galaxy Note layout.
>> MEIER: Oh, cool
>> ROCK: Which is so--I kind of have a weird
voice but yeah, we've got apps for all phones.
>> MEIER: Very cool.
So I guess the one question I had then is
based on that, have you seen a difference
in user engagement on tablet versus phone
the people reading longer on the tablet versions
of those metrics that you guys collect?
>> ROCK: Yeah, we do know that while people
will use the phone or the tablet really at
three main times a day--right while they are
eating breakfast, probably eating lunch and
once they get home and they're--around dinner
time.
>> MEIER: Sure.
>> ROCK: But we have noticed that later in
the day it's more tablet heavy.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> ROCK: So we're seeing a lot more tablet
use in a--I think kind of like when people
are sitting down--I guess all these commercials
and the--they're all right.
I mean people were in bed or sitting on the
couch and watching TV, pull out their tablet.
>> IN-LEWIS: For me, it's right when my 4G
LT phone runs out of battery that's when I
switch to the tablet.
>> MEIER: Time for the tablet, very nice.
All right.
Perfect.
So we--like I said we are well out of time
but thank you guys very much for coming on
and telling us about Instapaper and your experiences
there and thank you to all of our guests for
Mint, to TinyCo for joining us as well and
thank you everyone for watching and we will
be back tomorrow for the App Clinic.
>> IN-LEWIS: Yes, indeed, it's going to be
a very special episode of the App Clinic by
which I mean it will be an episode that will
run.
>> MEIER: Excellent.
That is special.
>> IN-LEWIS: Yes.
>> MEIER: That's very special.
We are looking at video player apps which
we will go in to look out last week but decided
that we needed to have a full extra week to
really understand what was going on in those
apps.
>> IN-LEWIS: Yes.
>> MEIER: So do tune in tomorrow for that.
We're also taking nominations for next week's
category which is Shopping Apps...
>> IN-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: We're actually going to choose the
apps that we're going to look at during tomorrow's
show before tomorrow show so do make sure
if you got a shopping app you'd like us to
take a look at that--you do throw it into
the moderation queue.
Thanks again for watching.
My name is Reto.
>> IN-LEWIS: I'm Ian.
>> MEIER: And we'll catch you later.
>> IN-LEWIS: Take care.